[Musik]
Ich denke, dass wir
in einigen europäischen Ländern und
osteuropäischen Ländern die
Anfänge einer antipopulistischen Gegenreaktion sehen,
die intelligenter ist
als die ursprüngliche Version. Wir sehen
neue Konfigurationen von Parteien, die wir
sehen
Liberale und Grüne beginnen zu
verstehen, dass sie
ihre Politik besser artikulieren müssen Ich meine,
wir haben es in
ähm gesehen, wir haben es ein bisschen in der
Schweiz gesehen, wir haben es in Spanien gesehen, wir haben
es in Polen gesehen, wir  Ich habe es in der
Slowakei gesehen, also ist
es unglaublich,
also ist es ein bisschen früh für mich zu sagen,
was ich darüber denke. Ich meine, das
Interessante an Zielinski
ist natürlich, dass das Berühmte an
ihm ist.
Oh ja, ja, das Interessante
Berühmte an ihm ist das  Er führte eine
Kampagne
als fiktive Figur durch, also war seine
Kampagne seine Fernsehsendung.
Er ist Komiker und Schauspieler und eigentlich
Produzent,
und die Sendung war die Geschichte einer Art
Geschichtslehrer in einer ukrainischen
Provinzstadt, der verunglückt ist  Er wird
Präsident
und trifft dann auf die ukrainische Korruption
und so weiter.
Das Interessante war, dass die
Werte dieses Programms
wirklich ansprechend sind. Der
Geschichtslehrer in dem Programm
ist ein Demokrat, er glaubt an Bildung,
er ist gegen Korruption, er ist ein Mann
von den leuten, die
du kennst, ist ein sehr gewöhnlicher mensch und er
scheint irgendwie
für viele gewöhnliche menschen in der ukraine zu sprechen.
ich denke
, das seltsame daran ist,
dass wir natürlich keine ahnung haben, ob die figur
, die er im fernsehen spielt, er selbst ist
Ich würde sagen, dass das teilweise stimmt, es
war eine Wahl gegen Poroschenko und
gegen die Wahrnehmung, dass die Ukraine
immer noch von korrupten Oligarchen dominiert wird,
aber Sie wissen, es klingt bizarr, aber noch einmal,
die Werte,
die in diesem Programm ausgedrückt werden, und die Werte,
die von Zielinski in der Form ausgedrückt werden
Seines Charakters
sind ansprechende Werte. Sie kennen einen kleinen
Kerl, der für
Menschenrechte kämpft, oder nicht, Sie wissen nicht, dass Gerechtigkeit
wirklich das bessere Wort als Mensch ist
rechte
ähm eine gerechtere und bessere
gesellschaft wollen ich meine es ist keine unattraktive
botschaft
demokratischer
konflikt faszinierend
ich denke sieh her die ukraine war bis vor kurzem
kein land sie hatte keinen
eigenen staat
bis 1991 die menschen sahen es als teil der
Karte Sie dachten, es sei ein Teil von Russland,
sie verstanden nicht, dass es eine
separate Identität oder sicherlich keine
separate Sprache hatte,
ähm, und deshalb gibt es eine gute
Erklärung oder eine Art
vernünftige, sowieso verständliche
Erklärung dafür, ähm, in
jüngerer Zeit, ähm, ich  Stimmen Sie zu, Sie wissen,
dass
2014, als der Krieg ausbrach, natürlich viel über die Ukraine berichtet wurde,
aber ich denke, dass die mangelnde Berichterstattung
und das mangelnde Verständnis der Ukraine
auch eine Art schlechtes
Bewusstsein seitens des Westens darstellen,
warum  Hat die Ukraine korrupte Oligarchen
und warum hat Russland tatsächlich korrupte
Oligarchen? Einer der Gründe dafür
ist, dass westliche Banken und westliche
Finanzinstitute
dies zugelassen haben  dered das
Geld Sie wissen, wir
Sie wissen, dass viele dieser ukrainischen
Oligarchen hier leben, Sie wissen, nicht allzu weit
von diesem Fernsehstudio entfernt,
und sicherlich gibt es das
in der Schweiz, natürlich,
ähm, und wir haben, wie Sie wissen, wir sind so
stolz auf unsere Korrupten  saubere Gesellschaften, aber
eigentlich machen wir die Arbeit,
ähm, wir machen diese Art von
Drecksarbeit, die stattfindet, und
Sie wissen, im Äther, im
Internet, in den
Finanzmärkten, was
dies zulässt,
ähm,
also ich meine dort  Sie wissen, dass es
verschiedene Antworten auf diese Frage gibt,
die ich Ihnen
ein paar Jahre gegeben hätte, und es
gibt verschiedene Antworten, die ich Ihnen jetzt geben würde.
Ich meine, jetzt, klar,
wir haben ein Interesse daran,
den ukrainischen Staat zu erhalten,
wir haben ein Interesse  in der ukraine zu helfen sich zu
verteidigen
ähm du weißt du ukraine bleiben
wir wir die freien gesellschaften des westens wir
europäer
wenn du willst ähm du weißt es du weißt es
ist in unserem interesse, dass es
ein großes pro-europäisches u gibt
Ich weiß, dass du zumindest einen demokratischen
Staat
anstrebst, du weißt, dass du zwischendurch die Europäische
Union in Russland bist. Ähm, es verändert wirklich das
Machtgleichgewicht.
Ähm, es ist gut für uns, es ist gut für den Handel,
es ist gut fürs Geschäft,
ähm, letztendlich wird das ein ähm du sein  wissen, dass
dies ein guter nachbar für europa sein wird,
wenn es sich in diese richtung entwickelt, und sie
wissen, dass dies
sowohl aus geopolitischer als auch
aus wirtschaftlicher sicht
sehr in unserem interesse liegt,
weil es ursprünglich der ursprüngliche grund dafür war
der krieg gegen die ukraine
ähm hatte fast nichts mit ukraine
zu tun und alles mit putin und seinem
wunsch an der macht zu bleiben
es ist eine längere geschichte aber ganz kurz
gesagt putin hatte in den ersten jahren als er
präsident eine art argument mit den russen
okay  Ich bin korrupt, okay, ich bin ein Diktator,
aber zumindest wirst du reicher, ähm,
und das galt für die ersten
paar seiner ersten paar Amtszeiten
, die nicht mehr funktionieren,
weil die Wirtschaft nicht impro ist  ving für
alle, insbesondere für die leute in
den provinzen
und jetzt hat er ein anderes argument
und dann ich bin ich ich bin sie
paraphrasieren aber jetzt ist das argument in
ordnung
ich bin korrupt aber zumindest mache ich
russland  Wieder großartig, Sie wissen, dass Russland
ein großartiges Land wird. Wir sind wichtig
auf der Weltbühne.
Ähm, und die Eroberung oder
Kontrolle
über die Krim war eine enorme Art von
Auftrieb für dieses Argument.
Ähm, es war auch wichtig, denn denken Sie
darüber nach, wofür die Ukraine steht  Russland,
Sie wissen,
Sie wissen, es ist eine verlorene Provinz,
es ist ein ehemaliges Territorium,
und wenn es pro-europäisch wird, wissen Sie,
dass selbst die Vorstellung, dass es
eine Demokratie
werden könnte, sehr bedrohlich für das russische
System ist, weil
Sie wissen, dass es eine Herausforderung ist, wissen Sie  wenn
sie wissen, ob ukrainer demokraten sein können,
wenn ukrainer europäer sein können, warum
dann nicht russen und
putin hat große angst vor genau der art
von
aufständen, die 2014 in kiew stattfanden
. also muss er zeigen, dass er es ist  Sie
wissen, dass er dagegen ist, Sie wissen, dass
Russland sich von der
NATO-Erweiterung bedroht fühlt, war schon immer
lächerlich.
Ähm, Sie wissen, dass die Russen wissen, dass Sie
wissen, dass die NATO-Erweiterung stattfand,
als die USA Truppen aus
Europa abzogen und Russland versteht, dass die NATO es
ist  a
ist ein Verteidigungsbündnis, ähm, und sie
wissen auch, dass es nicht kämpfen kann und
niemals in Russland einmarschieren wird,
ähm, ich denke, das war schon immer eine
Art Linie, die die Russen benutzen, das ist ein
weiterer Grund, warum es den Russen nicht
leid tut, dass Putin  die verwaltung nutzt
sie wissen, das ist ein weiterer
grund, warum putin
das ist ein weiteres argument, warum er an der macht
sein sollte. denken sie daran, das ist ein
undemokratischer
diktator, das ist jemand, der
keine populären unterstützer hat, jeder, der sich dessen nicht
sicher sein kann,
also muss er es tun  weiterhin
Leute versorgen,
oh natürlich, ich meine, sieh dir das an, du kennst
diese Idee, den Ukrainern russische Pässe zu geben,
das ist eine Wiederholung von etwas
, das die Russen bereits
haben  Eine haben sie in diesen abtrünnigen
Republiken von Georgia gemacht, sie haben den
Leuten russische Pässe gegeben und dann ist ihre
Entschuldigung dafür, warum sie einmarschieren oder warum
sie Leute verteidigen, dass Sie
wissen, dass wir russische Bürger retten und retten müssen,
ähm, also ja, das ist die Ukraine  a ist ein
weiterer Schritt,
ich meine, das hat bereits begonnen,
ähm, ich meine, ich wusste nicht, dass die Sie wissen, dass
die ganze Sowjetunion, die
Sie kennen, jemals zurückkommen wird, aber
ja, dass Russland sich selbst wieder aufbauen
will  ein wichtiger geopolitischer
akteur und das ist teil von
putins rechtfertigung seiner legitimität ich
meine das ist,
dass sie wissen, dass das eine klare
version der
kontinuität ist,
also denke ich, dass sie wichtige unterschiede
zwischen dem heutigen russland und der sowjetunion sind,
und ich möchte nicht sagen, dass
alles so ist  genau so,
ähm, die Bücher waren, wie du sagst, sie sind
, weißt du, sie, sie waren in meinem Kopf
auch eine Art Trilogie, weil
sie alle ein Versuch waren, zu verstehen,
was sowjetischer Totalitarismus war und wie  Hat
es funktioniert,
und ich denke, die Russen, der derzeitige
russische Staat, wollen
genau dieses Modell nicht wiederholen, weil
dieses Modell am Ende natürlich gescheitert
ist, aber er versucht, Lehren daraus zu ziehen
, und er versucht, sie erneut anzuwenden, und zwar
sehr
oft  Taktiken, die sie verwenden, sind
mir vertraut,
zum Beispiel die russische Invasion auf der
Krim, wissen Sie, während ich es sah, hatte
ich gerade dieses Buch fertig geschrieben, das Buch über
den Eisernen Vorhang, ja,
und während ich es sah, dachte ich, oh,
ich wünschte, ich hätte es getan  Ich habe das gesehen, bevor ich mein
Buch geschrieben habe,
weil diese Invasion auf der Krim
so stattfand, dass
die Armee keine Uniformen trug und
niemand wirklich verstand, was
passierte, und
sowjetische Soldaten, die vorgaben,
ukrainische Soldaten zu sein, das ist genau das,
was in Polen passiert ist,
oh, es war  Es war das KGB-Spielbuch
, wissen Sie,
das von 1944 in 1945 aufgenommen und
in die Gegenwart gebracht wurde, und ich dachte, oh, und jetzt
verstehe ich es besser. Ich wünschte,
ich hätte es gesehen, und das  Wie
sie lokale kriminelle Banden und so weiter benutzten
und mit Menschen zusammenarbeiteten und
ähm, Sie wissen, um eine neue Krim-
Elite zu schaffen, um diese alte Elite loszuwerden, das
ist genau das, was sie vor
60 Jahren in Mitteleuropa getan haben,
Sie wissen, dass es einen Moment davon gab  in
den späten 1980er jahren, in dieser zeit der
pirastroika, gab es ein gespräch
über die vergangenheit,
aber als ich in den 1990er jahren viel in russland unterwegs war, hatten die
leute fast eine negative
einstellung dazu, sie sagten, na ja, wir haben
das alles in der besprochen  1980er
und schau, was passiert ist, du weißt, jetzt haben
wir wirtschaftliches Chaos,
alles ist gescheitert, und da war auch
fast sofort
dieses Gefühl, dass wir vielleicht nicht
mehr großartig sind, aber wir wollen nicht hören,
dass das vergangene Regime schlecht
war  der wunsch, eine
positive lektion aus der
russischen geschichte zu ziehen und sie
in die gegenwart zu tragen,
um putin versteht das, und ich denke,
eines der wichtigsten
dinge, die er getan
hat, war, die erinnerung an ihn wiederzubeleben  der
große sieg von 1945, der
jedes jahr in moskau mit
menschen in sowjetischen uniformen
und truppen mit sowjetischen fahnen gefeiert wird,
absolut ja, aber es ist ein ganz
besonderes stück der vergangenheit, ich
meine, sie reden nicht über die
gulags, die sie nicht sind  Sie reden über
Massenmord, sie reden
über diesen Sieg über halb Europa
und diese Art von Moment des imperialen
Triumphs,
und das versucht Putin
zurückzubringen, ähm, und
es gibt definitiv keine Betonung auf der
negativen Seite, und
Sie können es  Ich habe kürzlich gesehen, dass es
sogar eine Art Wiederauferstehung von
Stalin als Helden gegeben hat,
und viele Russen, ähm, jetzt
wissen Sie, erinnern sich an ihn als eine
großartige Figur,
also ist es schwierig, und ich bin
zu verschiedenen Zeiten anders damit umgegangen,
ähm Sie  Kennen Sie das Gulag für ein Buch, das ich
geschrieben habe, als ich sehr kleine Kinder hatte,
ähm, und es gab einen Weg, wie Sie wissen, dass
ich daran arbeiten würde, und dann
würde ich irgendwie aus meinem Fenster schauen und ich
würde s  ee kleine Kinder spielen und ich
würde denken, oh, ich bin so glücklich, dass
du weißt, dass ich es bin, und so hatte es tatsächlich eine
Art, wie du weißt, ich würde ich würde
, würdest du wissen, es hat mich dazu gebracht, mehr von
der Welt zu schätzen, auf die wir uns freuen
und wie  Wir haben Glück, dass wir diesen unglaublichen Moment haben,
wir leben in diesem erstaunlichen
Moment in der Geschichte, wenn wir Frieden und
Demokratie haben und wir keinen Krieg haben und
ähm und so hatte es eine
Art positive Wirkung auf mich,
ähm das Gulag-Buch  und eigentlich ist das buch des eisernen
vorhangs auch voller geschichten von
menschen, die versuchten, ein trauma zu überwinden
oder zu kommen, damit
umzugehen oder es zu beheben oder sich zu wehren oder zu
protestieren oder sich sogar
mental darauf einzustellen und zu lernen und
das sind und sie sind tatsächlich viele
positive Geschichten in beiden Büchern. Das
schwierigste Buch für mich war über
die Hungersnot in
der Ukraine. Das jüngste, das gerade
auf Deutsch veröffentlicht wurde,
weil dies ein Buch über
Bauern ist  Analphabeten Bauern
oft verhungern und th  Ihre
Kinder sterben, und
es ist ein schrecklich schwieriges Thema, ähm, und
ich kann nicht irgendwie so tun, als ob
Sie fast nichts
Positives daraus ziehen können, es ist nur eine Sache, die Sie
durchmachen müssen, Sie müssen es sagen, ähm, wissen Sie
Nochmals als eine Art Poststempel, um sich daran zu erinnern, dass
dies dorthin führt, wo diese Art von
Regime hinführt.
Ja, es ist wichtig zu verstehen, dass
die ganze Demore eigentlich nicht
nur eine Kollektivierung war, sondern
tatsächlich von Gruppen von Menschen verursacht wurde, die von
Haus zu Haus gingen und
Lebensmittel beschlagnahmen, so dass den Leuten
buchstäblich das Essen weggenommen wurde,
manchmal all ihr Essen, Sie kennen
ihre Kühe,
ihre Schafe, Sie kennen ihren Vorrat,
was auch immer sie für Getreide gelagert hatten, also war es
kein
Unfall, der durch schlechte Politik verursacht wurde,
sondern es war tatsächlich Absicht
mörder ähm das ist wichtig
zu verstehen
ja ja absolut es war eine gezielte
maßnahme
es war so konzipiert und das war
die auswirkung die es hatte es war
teil von ag  größere Hungersnöte und es gab
andere, Sie können sich Kasachstan ansehen und dort
über eine bewusst andere Politik sprechen,
die auch zu einer höheren
Zahl von Todesfällen führte,
aber Sie wissen, dass die Ukraine für
Stalin in gewisser Weise
die Rolle spielte, die die Ukraine für Putin spielt,
meine ich, wenn Sie  Ich möchte über die historische Analogie sprechen.
Stalin sah die Ukraine als Problem an. Sie wissen,
dass es dort einen großen
antibolschewistischen Aufstand während des Bürgerkriegs im Jahr 1918 gab.
Nach Beginn der Kollektivierung im Jahr 1929
gab es eine weitere Serie von Bauernaufständen,
und er fürchtete ständig  dass sich
diese
unruhen in der ukraine irgendwann
auf russland auswirken würden
ähm dass es sich vielleicht auf
moskau auswirken würde dass es ausländischen truppen erlauben würde
wieder ins land zu kommen
wie während des bürgerkriegs
ähm und so fühlt sich putin ein bisschen
Über die Ukraine wissen Sie, dass es Moskau
betreffen kann Sie wissen,
was dort schief geht, kann uns betreffen
ähm und es hat diese Rolle
als Spoiler gespielt, den
Sie kennen  die letzten hundert jahre
instrumentals
ja absolut du weißt es war auch ein uh
du weißt lenin hat ukraine sehr viel gesehen du
weißt wir müssen ukraine haben
ähm du weißt wenn wir keine ukraine haben werden
wir verhungern und er hat es
natürlich besser verstanden  als jeder andere,
dass es Nahrungsmittelknappheit war, die überhaupt zu
der beschissenen Revolution geführt
hat,
also waren sie
von Anfang an so besessen von der Ukraine und sie
reden darüber,
ähm, und sie reden obsessiv darüber, ähm
und
die Zerstörung der Ukraine  Landschaft ähm,
Sie wissen, was Sie wissen, es ist wichtig, sich
daran zu erinnern, dass gestorbene Ukrainer
in einigen Fällen durch Russen ersetzt wurden,
ähm, in einigen Fällen durch Menschen aus anderen
Teilen der Ukraine
ähm, und sie hatten Richtlinien, um
Leute hereinzuholen, um diejenigen zu ersetzen, die verhungert waren,
ähm, aber sie hatten immer große Angst vor
diesen
Bauernunruhen, Sie wissen schon, und sie wollten das
beseitigen,
damit es so ist  Es stimmt, dass die ersten
Gespräche über den
Holodomor, die Ende der 1980er und Anfang der
1990er Jahre stattfanden
, eine Art Offenbarungsmoment für die
Ukrainer waren, und
Sie wissen wirklich, dass dies der Moment war, in dem die Nation
begann, sich zu konsolidieren, und wann
dies geschah
die opposition gegen die sowjetunion begann
diese diskussion war extrem wichtig
ähm der feiertagskrieg ist auch wichtig die
ukraine ist ein land das
viele verschiedene traumas durchgemacht hat
du kennst den krieg du kennst die säuberungen
absolut den holocaust ich meine da
gibt es alle möglichen
alle Arten von Traumata, die sie durchmachen,
ähm, aber
der Holodomor ist einer, der die Menschen
eher vereint als spaltet. Die
Menschen haben sehr unterschiedliche Erinnerungen an
den Zweiten Weltkrieg
Darüber hinaus, während der Holodomor eine Art
vereinigende Tragödie ist
und diese Rolle spielte, meine ich, lustig
genug, kürzlich
im Las  In vier oder fünf Jahren habe ich
das Gefühl, dass es ein bisschen weniger wichtig ist
als in den 1990er Jahren, und das liegt
daran
, dass Sie jetzt wissen, dass die Ukraine ein echter
Staat ist und einen Krieg um seine
Existenz gegen Russland führt, von dem
Sie wissen, dass es keinen gibt  Nicht, dass das
Gespräch über die Vergangenheit ein bisschen weniger wichtig ist,
und ich meine, eines der ironischen
Ergebnisse von Putins Invasion in der Ukraine
ist, dass es
eine Art nationales Identitätsgefühl stimuliert hat,
das vorher nicht da war  ähm und und trafen
Sie kennen Leute, die sich um das
eine Gefühl versammeln, dass wir Ukrainer sind,
einschließlich russischsprachiger ähm, und eines
der wichtigen Dinge bei der Zielinski-
Abstimmung, wenn wir darauf zurückkommen,
ist, dass er ein russischsprachiger Mensch ist
Die erste Sprache ist Russisch,
aber er ist eindeutig jemand, der sich
als Ukrainer identifiziert, und die Leute identifizieren ihn als
Ukrainer, und es gibt jetzt eine riesige
Gemeinschaft von russischsprachigen Ukrainern
, die Ukrainer sind,
und und und der Krieg hat dazu
geführt  Die Auswirkungen des Krieges
und das ist
ja, also denke ich, dass Putin einen Fehler in Bezug auf die Ukraine gemacht hat.
Als er seine erste
Invasion begann, nahm er an, dass Leute,
die Russisch und Ukraine sprachen, Russen waren,
und tatsächlich ist das nicht der
Fall  russischsprachige
bevölkerung ukraine die
nur russischsprachige ukrainer sind sie
wissen, dass dies ein zweisprachiges land ist
absolut zweisprachig
sie können zu öffentlichen treffen in kiew gehen
und die leute wechseln zwischen den
sprachen, die
sie kennen jemand wird die sprache, in der
sie sich wohlfühlen das ist
diejenige  du sprichst
ähm und jeder ist daran gewöhnt und
es ist richtig,
genau wie in der schweiz, aber die leute
haben viele ausländer, viele
europäer haben diese putin-erzählung akzeptiert,
du weißt, dass die
russisch sprechenden russen sein müssen,
aber natürlich sind sie es nicht  sind sie,
sie fangen langsam an,
ich meine, einige nicht langsam, irgendwie
immer, aber um
dich als ukrainer zu identifizieren, bist du dort ukrainisch
russisch sprache ukrainisch  Romanautoren, die
sich ukrainisch fühlen,
ähm, Sie wissen, da
fühlen sich viele russischsprachige Menschen sehr als
Teil des Landes, also ist das und
das ein bisschen
wichtig,
deshalb fällt es mir schwer zu wissen, dass
ich Teile zusammensetzen kann. Ich meine, ich nehme an, der wahre Auslöser
war der  Tatsache, dass ich das
Glück hatte, 1989 ein sehr junger
Journalist in Warschau
zu sein, und ich sah, wie das System
auseinanderbrach,
ähm, und
als es zusammenbrach, fing ich natürlich an, mich zu fragen,
okay, was war nicht ich meine,
denn 1989, Sie erinnern sich  es wurde angenommen, dass es
natürlich schrecklich war, jeder
hasste es, natürlich würde die berliner mauer
fallen, natürlich
würden die leute von ost- nach
westberlin hinüberlaufen, aber
wie kam es dazu, dass sie wissen, wie
es dazu kam  an erster Stelle
und ich fing an, Fragen darüber zu stellen,
und mir wurde klar, dass es ein großes
Loch in meiner Ausbildung gab, ähm, dass ich nicht
wirklich wusste, dass
ich wusste, dass Sie wissen, dass ich einige Kurse
darüber belegt hatte und so weiter, aber ich tat es nicht
Ich habe die Geschichte nicht gespürt  der gulag,
wie ich die
geschichte der nazi-lager empfinde, über die ich filme gesehen
und fiktionen darüber gelesen habe, läuft und ich hatte das gefühl
, dass es
wichtig war, es war irgendwie die fehlende
hälfte der geschichte und so  es hat es verdient, wiederentdeckt zu
werden.
Ich meine, es gab auch
die 1990er, die eine wirklich aufregende
Zeit waren. Ich meine, ich weiß,
vielleicht ist es für einige Ihrer Zuhörer
schwer zu glauben, aber eine wirklich aufregende Zeit
, in russischen Archiven zu sein. Sie wissen, dass
alles neu war  Sachen finden
, die noch niemand gelesen hat, oder zumindest
niemand,
niemand aus den Vereinigten Staaten oder Westeuropa,
ähm, und
da waren Dinge, die ich gefunden
habe, von denen ich glaube, dass niemand sie gelesen hat, und
das war dieses
Gefühl, dass man es könnte
etwas reproduzieren, das du etwas wirklich
Originelles machen
könntest, also muss ich dir sagen, dass die Tatsache, dass
meine Familie von dort
kommt, eine Art ist, dass wir uns daran erinnern, was
Amerikaner sind, wie
du weißt, dass ich mit dem Gefühl aufgewachsen bin,
absolut amerikanisch zu sein, wir nicht  Sprechen Sie darüber, woher wir
kamen,
und meine Verwandten kamen vor
langer Zeit im 19.
Jahrhundert
in die Vereinigten Staaten, einige im frühen 19. Jahrhundert, ähm, und
sobald sie in den Vereinigten Staaten
ankamen, versuchten sie, Sie so schnell wie
möglich zu vergessen  Wisst, dass Europa schlecht war,
lasst es uns vergessen, ihr wisst, dass wir jetzt Amerikaner sind,
also war es tatsächlich ich, der
diese bella-russische Verbindung entdeckte, oder
es war nicht wirklich Russland, es war
zu Vorkriegs-Zarais, Russland,
vor der Revolution, tut mir leid, Zaras, Russland
Ähm, es hieß nicht Biela Russland, dann ähm,
also war ich es, der es entdeckte, und ich
war derjenige, der dorthin ging und es fand, und
meine Familie war erstaunt,
also glaube ich, als erstes bemerkte ich, dass
Sie Hannah Arendt dort sitzen haben, ja,
ich  denke, es ist sehr, sehr wichtig,
sie zu vergleichen und gemeinsam darüber zu sprechen,
denn das waren zwei riesige totalitäre
systeme, die zur
gleichen zeit existierten, die
voneinander wussten, die
gegeneinander
ausspielten, und das ist der historiker timothy  Snyder
hat so brillant beschrieben, wie
Teile Europas
über lange Zeiträume zusammen geleitet wurden, und
es ist wichtig, dass
Sie wissen, dass Sie gemeinsam darüber nachdenken,
und ich habe versucht, dies im Gulag-Buch zu tun, das
ich in der Einleitung getan habe
Ich habe
die beiden Arten von Lagern sehr explizit verglichen,
aber wenn ich darüber schreibe
, versteht man natürlich
auch die Unterschiede. Ich
ähm, sie waren nicht gleich, sie waren nicht
identisch
Ich weiß, es gibt viele Arten, in denen sie anders sind, aber ich
denke,
ich denke, sie sind es, wenn wir
uns weiter von dieser Zeit entfernen und
auf die Geschichte der zweiten Hälfte des
20. Jahrhunderts zurückblicken, wird es anders  Es ist
selbstverständlich, gemeinsam darüber zu sprechen, und
es wird nicht mehr
wie ein Tabu erscheinen, wie es vor
20 oder 30 Jahren für uns alle galt, selbst als ich
an der Universität war
, war es immer noch eine Art Tabu, und
es ist nützlich, das zu tun  analog  Ihr wisst,
es lohnt sich, ich meine, ich denke,
es ist wichtig, ein bisschen hinzuschauen und
ein bisschen darüber nachzudenken, was das Wort
totalitär
bedeutet. Ähm, die Leute haben neuere, ihr
wisst, kürzlich
haben religiöse Historiker gesagt,
das ist ein bedeutungsloses Wort, denn
eigentlich  in diesen beiden systemen gab
es menschen, die mit der
regierung nicht einverstanden waren es gab unabhängige
institutionen es gab
im hitlerdeutschland noch freie
unternehmen und in stalins russland
gab es
regionen und es gab andere unabhängige
akteure ähm,
aber beide hatten sehr ähnliches
Es gab eine Art
totalitären Ehrgeiz, der darin bestand
, nicht nur die Wirtschaft und nicht
nur die Politik, sondern auch die Kultur,
die Art und Weise zu kontrollieren, wie die Menschen denken, auch die
Bildung, und beide
teilten die Überzeugung, dass dies möglich sei,
mit anderen Worten, dass man
jeden dazu bringen könne
genauso denken
ja und und das und das und dass
dies ein machbares und mögliches
ziel in anderer arbeit war  Um alle gleich denken zu lassen
und Meinungsverschiedenheiten zu beseitigen, sei es durch
Inhaftierung oder Tötung
oder einfach durch Umdenken,
gab es einen großen Glauben an das
,
was wir heute nennen
pr
Sie wissen, dass Sie die Denkweise der
Menschen ändern und die Menschheit
in diese eine Form passen könnten, und beide
Systeme teilten diesen Glauben,
auch wenn keines von ihnen das jemals wirklich erreicht hat
, ich meine, keines von ihnen war
jemals vollständig totalitär
ähm und  vor allem in mitteleuropa,
dass sie wieder dieses ziel hatten, das zu tun
, und sie haben es nie geschafft,
sie haben es nie geschafft
, sie wissen, das ist sie wissen, das system ist
immer wieder gescheitert und es
gab ständig krisen und so weiter, aber
der glauben  dass dies
die Absicht war und das Wichtige war,
was die beiden Systeme gemeinsam hatten, und
es lohnt sich
, zu verstehen, wo
sie einige gemeinsame Wurzeln haben, i  Das heißt, sie
haben Sünde
im Denken des
frühen 20. Jahrhunderts,
absolut nein, das sind zwei wichtige
Teile der Geschichte. Ich meine,
die Lager waren ungefähr, ähm, Sie wissen schon
, und es ist sehr wichtig zu
verstehen, was ein Konzentrationslager ist,
es ist kein Verbrecher  gefängnis und es ist
kein kriegsgefangenenlager
es ist ein gefängnis für menschen
die
kein strafgesetz gebrochen haben aber die
irgendwie nicht mit dem politischen
ähm dem mainstream der politischen
ansicht
ähm und so weiter übereinstimmen  Gefühl, dass diese
Lager in beiden Gesellschaften ähnliche Funktionen hatten, also taten
sie es
leid, der Gulag und die Nazi-
Konzentrationslager waren
Lager für Menschen, die keine Kriminellen sind,
aber anders denken oder
oder oder irgendwie nicht hineinpassen oder  andere
ähm, also hast du absolut Recht und sie
und beide Systeme hingen davon ab. Ich meine, damit hätten
sie nicht funktionieren
können.
Ich konnte nicht existieren,
aber Ihr zweiter Punkt ist noch
wichtiger, weil wir sehen, dass dies immer
wieder vorkommt. Beide hingen sehr
stark davon ab
, eine Lüge zu verkaufen, wissen Sie, eine
Vision der Gesellschaft zu verkaufen, die nicht wahr war und
die es musste  deshalb
ständig
bekräftigt werden ähm weißt du in der sowjetunion war
es eine lüge darüber
ähm was sozialismus war und was
er werden würde
ähm du weißt und du weißt und
was erreicht wurde und sie mussten
ständig lügen und die nazis  das system war
das gleiche sie wissen, es musste eine
ständige lüge darüber geben, was deutschlands
problem war und ein versuch ihnen
zu erklären, dass die juden die ursache dafür waren
und so weiter und die verwendung
von lügen und die verwendung einer art von
unterstützung  Das System
war absolut ein Merkmal
beider Systeme, und wie Sie sagten
, versuchten beide auch in gewisser Weise,
ihre Anhänger mit allen Arten von Lügen zu ertränken. Sie wissen, dass
die Lügen so
häufig und so oft waren, dass es den
Menschen sehr schwer fiel, sie zu kennen  w was
war wahr und was nicht wahr Ich meine eine
Idee von
objektiver Berichterstattung eine Idee von neutralen
Beamten Sie wissen schon eine Idee von
unabhängiger
Justiz unabhängige Richter Keines von
beiden existierte in einem dieser beiden Systeme,
weil dies die Existenz einiger implizierte
Sie kennen eine Quelle außerhalb der Politik,
die irgendwie neutral sein könnte, ist
das Ihr
oh, das ist sehr viel, das ist, das ist,
äh,
ein sehr zentraler Teil dessen, was Putin
versucht zu tun, er versucht es zu tun,
obwohl er Sie wissen, dass er es nicht tut  hat ein
riesiges
System geschaffen, eine enorme Ideologie
, an die jeder glauben muss,
und Sie wissen, aber er hat es geschaffen, und Sie wissen,
dass er versucht hat
, neue Wege zu finden
, um den Glauben und den Glauben der Menschen an das,
was sie sehen und lesen, zu untergraben  und höre
ähm und das tut er, wie du sagst,
absolut durch den Einsatz moderner
Kommunikation und insbesondere sozialer
Medien, was
ich meine, ein wunderbares Beispiel war, als das
Flugzeug
die malaysische KI abstürzte  rliner, der von amsterdam gestartet war, der
über der ukraine abgestürzt war und
in der ostukraine abgestürzt
war und der von einer
russischen rakete abgeschossen worden war,
ähm, was war putins reaktion darauf, dass
es nicht nur war, zu sagen,
wir leugnen es, nein, er hat abgesetzt  er und die
russische regierung haben ein dutzend
verschiedener theorien aufgestellt, sogar
wissen sie, dass es ein flugzeug gab, das
mit toten körpern abhob und
absichtlich explodierte, wissen sie, oder es gab ein anderes
flugzeug, das versuchte, putins plan abzuschießen,
dutzende und mehr  Dutzende von Jungfrauen,
irgendwie plausibel, manche völlig unglaubwürdig,
manche verrückt
, weißt du, und sie kamen in allen
verschiedenen Formen russischer Medien heraus, in
sozialen Medien und im Fernsehen und so weiter,
und als Folge davon gab es eine sehr
gute Reihe von Interviews, die im
Radio geführt wurden  für europe radio liberty in
moskau ein paar tage später und sie
interviewten leute auf der straße und sie
sagten, du weißt,
wer das flugzeug abgeschossen hat, und die leute
sagten, ich weiß es nicht
und ich weiß  Ich werde nie wissen, dass es unmöglich ist,
genau unmöglich zu wissen, dass sie
nach dem Versuch, Skripal zu ermorden,
dasselbe getan haben. Diese Verwendung von Gift in Großbritannien
30 oder 40 von ihnen,
also ist es die gleiche Idee,
das Internet zu überschwemmen oder
den Nachrichtenraum mit
Millionen verschiedener Lügen zu überfluten,
und dann werden die Leute desorientiert und
sie wissen nicht, dass es
wahr ist
werden
angegriffen dass unser system verteidigung braucht
dies ist sehr stalinistisch ich meine stalins
paranoia meinst
du weißt wenn du eines der
interessanten dinge liest wenn du liest
wie er in den 1930er jahren über die ukraine sprach und schrieb
er redet ständig über die
umfragen
du kennst die umfragen
Sie werden einfallen Sie kennen Pilsudski, der dann der
Anführer von Polen ist Sie wissen, dass es eine
Verurteilung gibt schläft nicht Sie wissen, dass er
es tun wird
ähm und da ist diese Panik wegen Polnisch
Invasion, die jeden Moment kommt,
und natürlich, wenn Sie die Geschichte
Polens in dieser Zeit kennen, hatte Polen nicht die
Absicht, einzudringen,
Sie wissen, dass dies eine imaginäre Art von
paranoider Vorstellung darüber ist, was
passieren könnte, die er verewigt
hat, wissen Sie vielleicht  weil er daran geglaubt hat,
aber auch weil es nützlich war,
und putin macht wieder etwas sehr ähnliches
,
wir haben die nato bereits erwähnt, sie kennen diese
idee, dass die nato einmarschieren wird, die nato
umgibt uns
über die
NATO und weiß ganz genau, dass es
nicht
weiß, dass es nicht dabei ist, in Russland einzumarschieren,
du weißt, dass niemand in irgendeinem NATO-Land darüber
spricht, das zu tun
Es ist auch sehr
wichtig,
was die Russen 2014 gesagt haben, als
der
ukrainische Präsident aus dem Land geflohen ist und
sie und Sie wissen, dass sie Neuwahlen
abgehalten haben und einige
und Poroshe  nko übernahm, sie sagten,
dies sei ein Nazi-Putsch gewesen,
das seien Nazis,
ja, das seien Nazis, und
seitdem spreche sie über sie
als Nazis, was
ihr Gespräch über den neuen
Präsidenten der Ukraine natürlich sehr schwierig mache,
denn wenn die Ukraine  wird von Nazis geleitet,
wie hatten sie dann nur eine sehr freie
Wahl, bei der
Poroschenko verlor, und sie mochten auch
Zielinski, der ursprünglich jüdisch ist,
also wissen Sie, es wäre sehr
interessant zu sehen, wie ihre Propaganda
dieser
komplizierten neuen Realität gegenübersteht
also die beängstigendste entwicklung für
mich heute
Ich meine, ich rede und schreibe viel über
russland, du weißt, es ist mein
, du weißt, ich spreche russisch, ich
mache das seit vielen jahren, aber die
beängstigendsten entwicklungen in diesem bereich
finden tatsächlich statt  China
und das liegt daran, dass die Chinesen
das herausgefunden haben, dass sie verstehen, dass sie
durch soziale Medien und künstliche
Intelligenz nicht nur wissen können,
was ihre Bürger sind  Sie
wissen
, was sie tun und kaufen und so weiter, sie können wissen,
was sie fühlen, welche Emotionen
sie ausdrücken, wie sie
miteinander kommunizieren,
und sie können eine Art von Kontrolle
aufbauen, die wir noch
nie zuvor in der Geschichte gesehen haben  ähm und Sie können
sehen, wie sie damit experimentieren. Ich meine,
die schlimmsten und beängstigendsten
Konzentrationslager, die wir heute haben,
befinden sich gerade
in der uigurischen Provinz in China, und dies
ist die Region der muslimischen
Minderheit, in der es sehr
große Lager gibt,
ähm, die Sie haben  wissen, sind für
Dissidenten, sie sind für Leute,
die nicht mit dem System
mitgemacht haben, und wo Leute überwacht werden, aufgezeichnet
ähm,
wo du weißt, dass überall Kameras
sind und wo
das System wieder darauf ausgelegt ist, Umerziehung zu machen,
und
du kennst dich  kennen und um Sie zu trennen
, kennen Sie eine schwierige und möglicherweise
bedrohliche Dissidentenpopulation,
und dies wird absolut unter Verwendung
moderner Technologie unter Verwendung von KI unter
Verwendung von ähm, die Sie kennen, unter Verwendung der
Informationen, die Sie kennen, durchgeführt  Ich kann aus dem, was die
Leute in den sozialen Medien schreiben,
absolut entnehmen. Ich meine, ich würde
insbesondere in diese Provinz China gehen. Nicht
ganz
China ist ein kompliziertes, sehr großes Land,
ähm, und bis jetzt hatte die
Führung keine totalitären Ambitionen,
ihnen ging es gut  Mit
Leuten, die ihre eigenen politischen Gespräche führten
und es ihnen nichts ausmachte, gab es ein gewisses
Maß
an Freiheit, wissen Sie,
solange Sie nicht versuchten, eine
politische Partei darum herum zu gründen, solange Sie
nicht herausforderten
Das System, Sie könnten sagen, was Sie
wollen, es gibt keinen Ehrgeiz, zu kontrollieren, was
jeder sagt und denkt,
aber die Frage ist jetzt eine tiefere,
ob es nicht so sein wird, dass sie Sie
kontrollieren, indem sie Sie verhaften, sondern ob
sie
versuchen, die Gespräche zu gestalten, die
Sie führen.  Wenn
Sie wissen, dass Leute bezahlt werden,
um Dinge zu posten, ich meine, wir sehen es ein
bisschen in unserem eigenen Internet, wissen Sie,
was diese Botnets sind und was
diese bezahlten Trolle sind, von denen Sie wissen, dass sie hinein
wollen  Ich meine, das ist
das Gleiche,
das ist das Gleiche, obwohl
es nicht ganz so kontrolliert durchgeführt wird,
aber ja, die Chinesen versuchen, die
Emotionen der Menschen zu formen. Sie verwenden
dieses System des sozialen Kredits, damit
Sie wissen, dass Sie es haben  zu öffnen,
ob du gelaufen bist, ob du
den richtigen Fahrpreis für die U-Bahn bezahlt
hast, du weißt, all diese Dinge
wird es geben, es wird jetzt eine Art geben, dass
du einen Kredit hast, wie die Leute einen
finanziellen Kredit haben, du wirst jetzt einen haben
Sozialkredit
ähm und wenn Sie wissen, dass Sie, wenn Sie die
Regeln brechen, kein Handelsticket
kaufen können,
oder Sie wissen, dass
Sie für Ihren Job nicht befördert werden, und das
alles ist das  Neue Möglichkeit, dass ich denke, dass
wir sehr vorsichtig sein müssen
[Musik]
-Individuen,
also müssen Sie sich verschiedene
Gesellschaften in verschiedenen Phasen ansehen, aber
Sie kennen die Fähigkeit, offene
Gespräche
zu führen, um sogar auf lokaler Ebene
oder oder ähm oder
Fabrikebene oder Gemeinschaft zu organisieren  Ebene ähm
du kn  ie Fähigkeit, über
Ihre Führer zu lachen, ja, ich meine, es
gibt ein Kapitel in meinem Buch über
meinen Eisernen Vorhang, es gibt ein Kapitel
über Widerstand,
und natürlich gab es in den 1940er und 1950er Jahren und
in Mitteleuropa keinen wirklichen
Widerstand  In Polen gab es in
den ersten paar Jahren bewaffneten Widerstand
und dann
gaben sie auf, aber es gab
andere Arten von Widerstand und
es gab Leute, die
alternative
Musikgruppen oder alternative akademische
Gesellschaften gründeten, es gab geheime Universitäten, von denen
Sie wissen, dass es Leute gibt
einander unter vier
Augen unterrichten ähm und fast alle davon waren
Organisationen, in denen
ähm, Sie wissen, die Leute stimmten zu,
auf der Grundlage von Ehrlichkeit miteinander umzugehen
und
die Lügen des Regimes draußen zu lassen, ich meine, so
viel davon war organisatorisch  und
eines der Dinge, vor denen ich in der Gegenwart Angst habe,
ist, dass die Leute zu glauben scheinen, dass diese
Art von Organisation online durchgeführt werden kann.
Sie wissen, dass Sie ein Faceb erstellen können  ook group
und das ist das Gleiche wie ich
denke, dass Sie wissen müssen, dass Sie den
tatsächlichen menschlichen
Kontakt kennen  auf deinem laptop
ii denke, persönlicher kontakt ist immer noch
du weißt, wenn ich in einer solchen situation meine, in
der du versuchst,
eine art alternatives netzwerk
aufzubauen oder bestimmte
alternative werte am leben zu erhalten, dann ja, denke ich
Ich denke, ähm, das Reale, ähm,
du weißt, echte Kontakte sind enorm
wichtig
[Musik
] Eine lebendige Geschichte führen Geschichte schreiben Geschichte
verstehen
Lehren aus der Geschichte lernen
Über Geschichte in der Gegenwart sprechen und auf
komplizierte Weise ich meine eines der Dinge, die
ich gelernt habe  in den letzten jahren
kann
man wissen, dass zum beispiel victor orbans
ungarn viel zeit damit verbracht hat, über den
ungarischen kommunismus zu sprechen,
aber auf eine sehr einseitige art und Weise
, die desi ist  Um die Instrumentalisierung zu rechtfertigen
, ist es
auch wichtig, ein komplexes Verständnis der Geschichte offen zu halten, damit
Sie wissen, warum die Menschen die
Sowjetunion unterstützt haben. Denken Sie darüber nach,
was die Menschen angezogen hat. Sie wissen, dass es
nicht ausreicht, nur zu verurteilen  es
und sagen, wir waren alle dagegen, weil
wir eigentlich nicht alle dagegen waren. Ich
meine,
wir in Ungarn, wir in Polen, wir in Russland
denke das ist wichtig ähm
also der müller bericht ähm war auf der
einen seite
sehr nützlich weil er wirklich detailliert ist
ich meine das ich glaube die leute haben es nicht
genug gewürdigt dass der müller bericht
sehr detailliert zeigt was
die russen in der gemacht haben  Vereinigten Staaten
und es war nicht nur ein bisschen
Facebook-Werbung, Sie wissen, es war,
Sie wissen, dass sie durch das Land gingen,
sie bildeten Gruppen, die sie gründeten
, ähm, Sie wissen, dass sie c  Gegründete
Facebook-Gruppen, die sie gründen, wissen
Sie,
und unter falschem Vorwand
versuchten
sie, diese Art von rechtsextremen
Anti-Einwanderungsgruppen zu gründen, aber sie
versuchten auch, Wählerunterdrückung zu betreiben, also gründeten sie
auch eine Gruppe mit gefälschten Black Lives
Matters, die ihnen erzählten  Mitglieder sollten nicht
abstimmen,
diese waren digital, aber
es gab auch einige echte Maßnahmen.
Sie wissen, dass dies eine riesige Operation war,
und ich denke, das wurde
in diesem Streit darüber, ob
wir Trump anklagen sollen oder nicht, ein wenig übersehen, was
genau der Fall war  die russen tun und die
erstaunlichen mühen, die mueller unternommen hat
, um es zu beweisen, wissen sie, er hat die namen
der gru-offiziere,
die sowjetisch, ähm, tut mir leid, nicht die sowjetischen russischen
geheimdienstoffiziere,
die das alles ausgeführt haben, ähm, und das steht
alles in dem bericht, und das war
ähm und  Das war wirklich nützlich, weil
so viele Leute in der republikanischen
Partei bestritten haben, dass
irgendetwas davon jemals passiert ist, also ist das ein
wichtiger Teil davon
des Berichts, ich meine, der zweite Teil
davon war diese Frage, ob Trump
die Justiz behindert hat und
Mueller entschieden zu haben scheint, dass
dies nicht seine Aufgabe war,
mit anderen Worten, er würde nicht sagen, dass
er nur Beweise vorlegen würde
und  dann ist es Sache des Kongresses zu entscheiden,
wie es dem Team geht, ja
was zu tun ist, um die Schlussfolgerungen zu ziehen, ähm,
ich ärgere mich darüber, weil
ähm, wissen Sie, ich denke, obwohl der Kongress
weitere Untersuchungen durchführen wird,
ähm, es ist klar, dass wir eine
Handelshälfte
haben  der Kongress
das von den Demokraten geleitete Repräsentantenhaus der
Senat wird von Republikanern geleitet
Sie wissen, dass Trump nicht weißt, dass er möglicherweise
in dem Sinne angeklagt wird, dass das Haus
ihn verurteilen kann,
aber er wird nicht vom Senat vor Gericht gestellt,
was erforderlich ist
Unter der US-Verfassung ist
es also eine Art Sackgasse, jetzt
gibt es
also, ich denke, äh, Trump, ich meine, ich denke,
Russland war wirklich in Trump investiert,
sie wollten, dass Trump gewinnt, ähm und eines
der Dinge  Mueller-Bericht nicht,
dass er sich nicht
mit Trumps Beziehung zu Russland befasst, die viele Jahre zurückreicht,
ähm, viele Sie kennen Leute
aus dem Finanzbereich in New York, nehmen an, dass
Trumps Geschäfte, weil Trump
nicht in der Lage war,
normale Bankfinanzierungen zu erhalten  New Yorker
Banken, weil er so oft betrogen hat
und er so oft bankrott gegangen ist, sie,
sie,
sie, sie haben ihn satt, ähm, und
viele Leute haben lange angenommen, dass ein
Großteil seiner Finanzierung tatsächlich russisch war,
wir wissen es immer noch nicht  dass Mueller das
anscheinend nicht untersucht hat und
das ist eine meiner anderen Enttäuschungen
darüber,
aber seine, aber seine Dinge, die er
auf der Platte gesagt hat, die
viele Jahre zurückreicht, um eine
Verbindung zu
einer Zustimmung zu Putin und Putinismus und so weiter zu implizieren
von
und wir wissen von einigen finanziellen
Beziehungen, weil wir wissen, dass er
versucht hat, während des gesamten US-Wahlkampfs 2016 einen Trumpfturm in Moskau zu bauen
unternehmensinteresse an russland russland hatte ein
geschäftsinteresse an ihm und so
betreibt russland den strom.
putin ist russland. sie suchen nach leuten,
mit denen sie eine leicht
korrupte oder
geschäftliche beziehung haben können
Was sie mit Aaron Banks gemacht haben, dem
Leiter der Geldgeber der Brexit-
Kampagne in Großbritannien,
ähm, es gibt eine Reihe anderer Beispiele in
Italien und anderswo,
sie suchen nach Leuten, die für
diese Art von Gesprächen empfänglich zu sein scheinen,
und dann versuchen sie, sich zu etablieren
Beziehungen zu ihnen,
und das sieht aus wie eine sehr alte
Beziehung, die sie schon
seit langer Zeit mit Trump haben,
ausländische
[Musik],
also ziehe ich den inkompetenten,
desorganisierten Menschen vor, der autoritär wäre, gegenüber
dem
wirklich gut organisierten, intelligenten
, also eigentlich nein, meine ich  Einer
der Gründe, warum Trump nicht so gefährlich ist, wie
er sein könnte,
ist genau das, was Sie sagen, und Sie wissen,
dass er die meisten Probleme, die er tot hat, nicht versteht  ling mit er
trifft aus einer Laune heraus seltsame Entscheidungen er
hört nicht auf Berater
ähm er handelt ohne Wissen Sie
kennen das und diese Art von Inkompetenz und
auch dieser Mangel an Wissen
nicht nur von ihm, sondern von den Menschen um
ihn herum, wie man das nutzt  Wir Bürokratie
ähm ist wirklich wichtig Ich meine, es ist
eines der Dinge, die Sie wissen, eines der
Dinge, die
Sie wissen, hat ihn dazu gebracht, Sie wissen zu lassen, dass
einer der Rückschläge gegen ihn
von der Bürokratie und von Leuten kam,
nur von Leuten, die ihm sagten, nein, Mr
President, das geht nicht, das ist legal
und das steht eigentlich auch im Mueller-
Bericht. Viele, viele Leute
um ihn herum
weigern sich, Dinge zu tun, die sich weigern
, seine Befehle
von Trump Einstein Einstein auszuführen,
so weit, aber wir werden sehen, ich meine  Wir
wissen, dass das Problem mit Trump darin besteht, dass
ich sogar unterschätzt habe,
wie viel Schaden er anrichten kann, indem er nur
redet, Sie wissen schon, welche Gesetze
er verabschiedet hat und
so weiter  h er versucht
irgendwie, ähm, Sie wissen schon, ein Gefühl der
Stammesidentität unter einem Teil der
Vereinigten Staaten zu schaffen,
Sie wissen, dass er gegen den anderen Teil
die Autorität
unabhängiger Institutionen untergräbt. Ich meine,
Sie kennen nicht nur die Presse, sondern auch die
Justiz  Ich meine, das ist alles,
ähm, das ist alles sehr gefährlich und
kann längerfristige
negative Auswirkungen haben, und er ist nicht der
einzige, der es tut, es gibt andere Mitglieder
der republikanischen Partei, es gibt einen Teil
der Linken, der so etwas auch tut,
aber dich untergräbt  Wissen Sie, wir haben
bereits diese objektiven
neutralen Institutionen des Staates erwähnt, die
als Machtblockade dienen können.
Das ist
auf lange Sicht unglaublich gefährlich. Das ist,
was in Nazi-Deutschland passiert ist. Ich meine
, das haben die Bolschewiki immer
gehasst
Sie kennen diese Zwischeninstitutionen, die
sie immer für eine Täuschung hielten.
Sie wissen, dass sie Parlamente nicht mochten.
Sie mochten keine Richter. Sie mochten
die Presse nicht
Ich meine, ich fände es
besonders schlimm, wenn er wiedergewählt würde, wie
Sie sagen, ich meine, das wäre
eine Art Bestätigung dafür, dass seine
verfassungswidrige Sprache, die
bisher hauptsächlich Sprache ist,
und sein Instinkt
, Institutionen zu untergraben,
Sie wissen, das wäre  für ihn und für
die menschen um ihn herum eine bestätigung, dass
er recht damit hatte,
und ich würde denken, dass eine zweite trumpf-
amtszeit viel schlimmer wäre
als die erste auf der welt
, wegen der tiefen
einbeziehung russlands  der wahlkampf trump
hat sehr darauf geachtet, sich von
russland fernzuhalten und
nicht zu sehr darin verwickelt zu sein, ich meine wir,
außer natürlich seinen sehr seltsamen
privaten treffen mit putin, bei denen
bei einigen anscheinend keine wir-
person anwesend war und die  Die einzige
Transperson, ein anderer Präsident, war
Putins Übersetzer, das ist sehr seltsam, ähm,
und wir haben auch alle die sehr
seltsame Pressekonferenz in Helsinki gesehen, bei der
Trump anscheinend mit Putin über
sein eigenes Ja übereinstimmte
über sein eigenes fbi und cia ja, sehr, sehr
seltsam,
aber eigentlich hat er bis jetzt nicht, du
weißt, er hat sich von etwas ferngehalten,
ja, es ist sehr meine theorie, und ich
schreibe das nicht, weil ich es nicht beweisen kann, dass meine
theorie trumpf ist  er selbst
glaubt, dass er teilweise mit
russischer unterstützung gewählt wurde
und dass er deshalb so nervös und
seltsam gegenüber putin ist, das vermute
ich, aber ich aber ich weißt du weißt es aber ich weiß es nicht
ähm und dann weiß er natürlich, dass
er eine lange hatte  Geschäftsinteresse an Russland
seit vielen Jahren und so hat
er sich eigentlich von dieser Politik ferngehalten,
aber natürlich könnte sich das in einem
zweiten Semester
ziemlich dramatisch ändern,
und entgegen Kursartikeln ist
es eine schwierige Frage. Ich denke, es
gibt einige Umstände zum Beispiel danach
Bürgerkriege,
wenn es nützlich ist, eine Weile nicht darüber zu sprechen,
es ist nicht so, dass sich die Leute nicht
daran erinnern oder nicht darüber schreiben sollten, aber
manchmal gibt
es eine Zeit, in der es
sinnvoll ist, dich einfach zu
behalten  Wissen Sie, das Warten auf Spanien ist ein
interessantes Beispiel dafür, aber es
gibt einige andere auf der ganzen Welt
, also ist es nicht so, dass Sie
Dinge nicht besprechen sollten,
aber manchmal ist es besser,
sie akademisch zu besprechen, sie privat zu besprechen
und
auf den richtigen Moment zu warten, um
sie zu besprechen  öffentlich öffentliche diskussion
kann sehr nützlich sein es war ein erstaunlicher
erfolg im nachkriegsdeutschland war
es an einigen anderen orten kein großer erfolg sie
wissen, dass
es möglich ist, eine dis zu manipulieren eine
öffentliche diskussion über geschichte
und man muss bereit sein  dafür
danke
[Musik]
dir